[Music]
you
hello friends welcome back to this last
section of decision-making which could
be the last concept with that we'll
discuss in this course on introduction
to cognitive psychology in the previous
lecture we discussed complex thought
process and under that we discussed two
basic phenomena in complex thought
process namely reasoning and judgment
reasoning and judgment when they finish
up they lead to the process of decision
making and that is the topic that we'll
be discussing in today's lecture so what
this lecture will be comprised of is
decision making what the term implies
what processes are involved in
decision-making how it is done what are
the various models of decision making
and at the end of it the various other
cognitive processes which interact with
this isn't making to effect idea or to
give rise to final choice so before we
go into the process of defining what is
decision-making
let's first revise a little bit on to
the topic of reasoning and judgment so
the last class on topics of reasoning
and judgment we thought and I showed to
you how this is the last step in any
cognitive process so within this whole
lecture series we have been studying
various cognitive processes starting
from perception pattern recognition in
perception to attention then leading to
the process of memory and following by
processes of language thinking and
problem-solving and then coming to the
higher order cognitive process of
reasoning judgment
season making now what does
decision-making actually imply and the
classes are in the lectures of reasoning
and decision-making we saw that
reasoning is basically a phenomena which
leads to verification of facts based on
current knowledge
so basically when the lower order
cognitive processes which are basically
perception attention memory and and and
these basic cognitive processes when
they produce an input or when they
produce a kind of a knowledge
representation a mental representation
these mental representations needs to be
further analyzed and process further
analysis and process of the mental
representations is generally done by the
process of thinking reasoning judgment
and decision-making so in in reasoning
what we tend to do is the mental
representation the solutions which have
been generated through or the kind of
output that has been generated to the
basic currently processes they are
evaluated or they are considered in
terms of the present information in
terms of the given information at that
point of time so basically reasoning is
a process of finding evidence for the
conclusions that are been generated or
there have been there are generated for
the kind of conclusions which have been
drawn from the basic of the cognitive
processes now from reasoning we move
into there are the second process which
is called
judgment so basically in reasoning we
define there are two kinds of reasoning
we have something called syllogistic and
conditional reasoning which is which are
part of reductive reasoning and then we
have inductive reasoning which has the
ephors kind of a statement two kinds of
reasonings are out there now the
reasoning process basically goes ahead
and
finds out evidences or provides
evidences of to support the conclusions
which have been generated as an output
in judgment what we tend to do is
looking at the conclusions we go ahead
and judge whether whatever the
conclusions have been brought up in
which of those conclusions are valid in
which of these conclusions are not valid
so let's say that the basic order
cognitive processes gave us a number of
conclusions and through the process of
reasoning we then go ahead and provide
evidences for the existence of each of
these conclusions which have been
derived so in a cognitive process or in
a let's say in a cognitive pipeline in
the process of perception attention and
memory we have generated an output now
this output or this kind of mental
representation which has been generated
from the basic level property processes
have to be supported by evidences and
reasoning is a process through which we
go ahead and provide the evidence of why
these conclusions are valid and not
judgment is a process through which we
look at those conclusions which are
valid in those conclusions which are not
valid and so these are something which
we have done in the previous classes
what is this isn't making this isn't
making is a process which is a step
ahead of judgment in judgment we look at
a number of conclusions we look at a
number of outcomes from the basic level
processes in the process of decision
making we made a choice so out of the
number of given available inclusions to
us through judgment and reasoning we
then make a choice according to our
needs according to our requirements of
which other choices which are the
options or which are the conclusions
which have been drawn from the basic
level our current processes should we go
ahead and
used and this choice process is actually
a very very risky process the reason
being that once we make a choice once a
number of options are available to us
here and we make a choice there are
always a chance that the choice will
backfire meaning which that if there are
four different options or four different
conclusions which can be drawn from a
particular mental representation or four
different interpretations of a
particular mental representation
choosing one representation or over the
other basically puts up puts us into a
situation where if the choice that we
are making is wrong we could have a
wrong judge wrong decision and that
could that could harm us in some way so
basically decision-making is then a very
complex process and this isn't making
what we need to do is we need to make
choices also another interesting thing
that we should remember here is that
when we are making choices in
decision-making when we are making the
same choices most the time that these
choices have to be made in uncertainty
or with certain amount of risk thus the
fact that human beings are not
calculating machines and human beings do
not have all the information available
for making a choice selection order the
number of options which have been given
to us so we tend to make these
selections which come out of judgment
through a process or through in a state
of uncertainty in a state of risk and so
what we tend to do as humans is we tend
to minimize this risk or uncertainty we
try to make decisions which do not
backfire on us so let's then take a look
at what is decision making and how do we
go ahead and make decisions because
these decisions are the ultimate or the
final point of any cognitive process
because these decisions finally decide
how the goal that we have said how do we
attain a goal so basically then this is
in making is a process of making a
choice one of the alternatives which is
been a
from the process of judgment and this
choice has to be made mostly in dams or
or in in situations where there is
considerable amount of risk present and
considerable amount of uncertainty
passes and for that we need to
understand how this decision process
really works and the various models of
decision-making which are available so
let then start with a very basic model
of decision-making
how do people actually go ahead and
decide let's take a very simple
situation for example a situation could
be in terms of identifying major course
that you would like to take when you
enter a college when people or when when
students freshman Center college the
very basic question which is in front of
them is to chose a major is to choose a
stream of study and so how do people go
ahead and make this choice of stream of
study so basically what they do is they
look at the number of courses which are
available and they look at the goals
that they have what they want to want
they want to become in their life and
based on the goals that they have based
on their personal values based on the
number of courses which are available
and based on so many other variables
they make a final choice and this choice
once made cannot be reversed that has to
be understood that once you have
selected a particular kind of a year so
what are the what is the flow chart or
how does our decision actually made or
how is the decision actually made so
this is a simple decision making flow
chart which explains how this isn't
really what so first the first thing is
to in any decision making process the
first step is to set a goal
first of all in making a decision in
making decisions among to exist you
people have to set some kind of a goal
so let's take this example of choosing a
major or choosing a particular branch of
study and then evaluate this particular
flow chart so let's say that somebody X
enters a college as a freshman and then
he has to make a choice of which a
particular subject to take or which
particular subject
choose for that process first yes to set
a goal this goal is to - the first step
in decision-making is setting a goal so
the person who's making a choice has to
first set a goal of what he wants to
become and this is the first step so
let's say somebody wants to become a
doctor he or she will not opt into
course which has mathematics and physics
onto it and will opt into courses reach
her closer to Medical Sciences and
closer to biology and those kind of
courses so first in decision making
process if you want to become a doctor
or if somebody wants to has a goal of
becoming a doctor into the medical field
or doing work with primates or animals
and in that case he has to choose that
kind of a set that goal first now once
that goal is set once once somebody says
that goal he has to then make plans and
gather information this is the second
step so before say picking up a major or
before taking up a stream of study first
step is setting a goal and somebody
events they have set up a goal that they
want to be in a medical field that they
want to do work on people they now have
to make plans the making plan step
basically evaluates of what has to be
done what are the requirements of this
kind of a study in a medical field so
you have to then make plans of what is
to be done and what is not to be done in
terms of making plan is which
universities to select which
universities are offering this kind of
courses which are what is the rating of
these universities which is the best
kind of rating within the medical field
which branch that you want to select and
so on and so for that kind of planning
has to be done for this planning to be
efficient or for this planning to
proceed you have to go through a step
which is called gathering information
and so if within this step what people
tend to do is to look at a number of
universities which are available which
offer these courses in medical so and in
number of universities are there what
kind of courses that they offer what are
the specializations are there who is a
good teacher what is the ranking of the
University and all those kinds of
information has to be catered and this
information says then has to be started
along several dimensions or several
requirements which people might
based on their values based on the
likeness for example one of the things
that people could decide is I want to be
a doctor but I don't want to
supposedly say practice dentistry and so
I want to work with basic anatomy or I
want to work with dermatology in these
cases they have to select the University
of that requirement or somebody would
say that I would I would like to work
too hard so I'll take a medical
university and so they wouldn't be going
for top class institutions and going for
secondary institutions and so on and so
forth other people would like to
specialize in certain areas and so they
would have to select hospitals or
Institute's which specialize for example
if somebody wants to work on to brain in
India they would like to go to NBR C and
so this kind of thing has to be there so
then you have to collect a number of
institutions which work on to brain and
you come to know that in India there are
three or four institutions which offer
you medical degrees or medical
specializations in brain and so you were
to apply to that and that is the process
which is there so first in any decision
making process the first step has to be
setting up a goal once the goal has been
set we gather information or people
gather information and then make plans
according to this information and this
process of setting the goal gathering
information and making plan is cyclic in
nature in the sense that as more and
more information comes to you your
plants keep on changing and so does the
goal keep on shifting and so this has to
be done until and unless people are team
a certain level of certain it is that
this is what I want to do and they get
satisfied with the incoming information
or the information that the FHA once
they have decided to go to a particular
Institute and be in a particular kind of
select a particular kind of major for
their graduation degree they have to
then structure their decision the
structuring or decision basically
requires you to follow what path do you
have to follow to carry out this
decision for example in structuring
decisions in terms of choosing a major
is basically understanding how do you go
and role what are the kind of activities
that you are going to do there and what
are the kind of tests that you are going
to do afterwards
and then which is the kind of practice
that you want to do and so this is
structuring this isn't how are you going
to take up this decision how you're
going to basically carry on with this
decision and then based on this
structure you know decisions making
looking at all the finer points looking
at all the pluses and minuses from all
the Institute's of your choice or all
the Institute's of your liking taking
all the benefits of one Institute and
the non benefits of that Institute and
comparing it with benefits and on
benefits of all available Institute's of
your liking you then go ahead and make a
final selection so basically this is how
the decision-making process really works
so this is how the flowchart of this is
in making processes
it starts up with setting up a goal then
fetching more information about then
making plans of how effective this
information is or making up plans of how
to go about in our team this code once
that is done we need to structure our
decision which basically means that we
need to recalculate the plusses and
minuses of all the options which have
been available so all the things check
coming out of reasoning and judgment all
the conclusions which are coming out of
reasoning and judgment we need to go
ahead and balance them on some some way
and then make a final choice and make a
final selection and so this is the final
step which is generally and this is
making so although all of these steps
require decision making but this is
where the final step of decision making
is all about so what is then how do we
proceed with decision making so as we
studied in the section on reasoning and
decision-making that judgment the
process of judgment which comes before
decision-making it suffers from a lot of
errors for example the three most errors
which affect the process of judgment is
the error or of using hereis such as the
availability here is the representative
furies and anchoring in judgment
theorists now what are these these are
some kind of mental shortcuts these are
some kind of shortcuts which people use
for making
gentlemen now since all information is
not available to people at all point of
time people use this kind of here is in
terms of the availability here is people
trust on their memory so based on the
memory whatever comes first to their
memory people make conclusions or people
make judgment based on that for example
the fact that if I ask people or if I
ask anyone what is the most common name
in India people will come up with which
word for example is is the most common
name but represents the most common name
in India people will come with the idea
that it is s or R this comes from the
fact that the dictionary has more number
of words under SNR and so this is called
the availability Harris because this
comes to us or this comes to the person
if people look into the memory these are
the two letters which comes to the name
so what people will tend to do is that
they will tend to know or they'll tend
to recollect the name of all the people
that they know and since most people are
from Essen iron in somebody's let's say
in somebody's nearby area and so that is
what they tend to do that it is
basically SNR and so this is this is
turning on or this is basically the use
of our laboratories in comparison to
this or in contrast to this basically is
the representative Furious which affects
judgment and this here is is basically
the one in which people look at data and
compare it with some representative
sample examples if you see somebody
who's 6 foot 2 inches tall 6 foot 3
inches tall the first thing that comes
to mind is he has to be a basketball
player because he is tall and so most
basketball player at all and so this has
to be basketball cat and this is
representative Yunus because what we
tend to do is we tend to use this basic
shortcut of taking this tall person and
matching him him with everybody who's
tall and this idea somewhere is inside
our head that everybody who's tall has
to be there and so these are some of the
kind of errors which are there for
example there are other errors or miss
calibration of confidence and the errors
of spotlight effect and so these are the
errors inject now despite these errors
which are coming from judgment that
occur when we make a judgement these
judgment from an important part of the
database for the process of decision
making
judgments are very important although
judgment can be routed or judgments has
afflictions or judgment can be affected
by a number of errors but judgments are
important to us why because they form
the very basic data or they provide the
very basic data for decision-making now
this isn't making in truth generally a
choice between alternatives as I said
now the process of judgment gives us a
number of alternatives gives us a number
of conclusions which are there is a
number of options which are there what
decision-making does is to make a final
choice or to make a final real liking
for a particular choice now with the
increase of number of alternatives now
there is another problem as the number
of alternatives increase as the number
of options increase the probability or
chance of alternatives being wrong also
increases leading to the increased risk
or unsecured choice what does this
really mean it means that if a number of
Fortnum's are available we have to do a
number of comparisons and so if let's
say if a process of judgment leads to
many number of alternatives then the
chances of the alternatives number of
activities being wrong also becomes more
and more or the probability of those
alternatives become more and more and
this chance or this probability that a
particular that some of these
alternatives are wrong will lead to
increasing the risk and uncertainty
let's say that a process results in only
two options now if there are two options
the chances of some one of these option
being wrong is 1/2 and so the chances of
the other option being right is always
half now if we increase this to four the
chances of a particular option being
right becomes 1 by 4 and the it being
wrong becomes 3 by 4 and similarly if we
keep on increasing the number of
alternatives the chances of an option
being wrong increases and this increases
the risk and uncertainty as number of
options increases the uncertainty in
risk also of
increases try to understand this in the
present consumer society with only a few
choices available a few brands available
for us to pick up we are very sure of
what to buy and what not to buy let's
look at final brands the number of
brands of fennel which are available now
since there are only couple of brands of
fennel which are available and so we
don't have to be very certain we don't
have to be very choosy and so these kind
of products are called low involvement
products and people don't have to do go
ahead and get themselves involved and
the choice is very easy but look at
beauty products now in beauty products
there are a number of changes which are
available and every day there is a new
choice which is out there and so as a
new as new and newer choices Gibbs gets
increased into or newer and your choice
gets included into what really happens
is that the chances of failure also
increases because people are not really
certain the risk increases as people
have not seen a new product or not
tested a new product the chances that it
will fail also increases and so this
increases that risk or this increases
the uncertainty
now there is something called the
threshold approach of choice thing to be
remembered is that as the number of
choices increases as the number of
alternative increases the risk of our
risk and uncertainty of failure also
increases or the risk or uncertainty in
making decisions also increases now
there is threshold to your choice which
were proposed by someone called Clements
and what it says is if a decision
depends on likelihood of an event
happening the attractiveness of the
option should increase as the
probability of the other event increases
so what what it really means is that if
a particular event or a particular
decision depends on an event another
event happening and if the second event
becomes more and more sure then people
will choose that option let's take a
shopping experience let's say that
somebody wants to buy something and this
buying of this product depends on let's
say whether a kind of rebate is given
onto it and so as you become more and
more sure that so you buying a product
depends upon whether something is
free with it or not so as you are
promised more and more that things are
becoming free or things are being given
free and for you to buy that particular
product as the people advertise as every
teaser makes more sure that you get free
things out of it your choice or your
likingness or your probability of buying
the particular product a also goes on
increasing so what it basically says is
that if an event is there if a
particular buying of a product is
dependent on some other event which
could be whether something is offered
with it or not and as the conformity or
as it becomes more certain that when you
buy a product a product with which you
think comes free with it that certainty
of it becomes more and more you will buy
product a and not buy product P because
product a is offering something which is
free and so the more certain you are
that it is being offered free the more
chances that you will buy product a
instead of P let's look at this in this
way so let's say that there are two
products a and B and these products have
some associate product C right it could
be that you are buying a washing machine
and this washing machine has an
additional accessory which is C which is
required for and so product a is product
both product a and B require this
accessory C no product a announces that
C comes free with a this accessory C
comes free with this washing machine
this C could be a dish loader or any and
any other thing which is there now the
more certain or the more confirm that
the manufacturer of a becomes with the
fact that they are providing C free
product a will be chosen more or product
B because pure product B is not a thing
C so is an event of if you buying a
washing machine
depends on whether C comes free with it
it or not and as C becomes more and more
certain you start buying product it more
and more and that is what is called the
threshold Choiza or threshold approach
to choice so basically it's stated as is
a likelihood that another event
happening that the attractiveness of an
option should increase as the
probability of other event
also increases now once that probability
reaches a minimum level of certainty the
alternative will be chosen and this is
called the threshold of culture choice
so as producers of product a confirm
that they are going to give C for free
you choose product a so till the point
of time that a and B both say that they
are going to offer C but you don't have
an idea you don't have any confirmed
news you have both these options for
buying a and B washing machines but the
moment that manufacturer of a say is
that it is certain it is a minimum level
of certainty is provided or given the
fact that they say that some charge some
minimum charges will be incurred from
you and then C will be given to you for
a very very minimum value but B doesn't
say anything about the accessory see the
product manufacturer of product B
doesn't say anything about the product
the buying of products C you will buy a
because a is not saying that some amount
of money will be taken from you I mean
your Martin C will be given and so this
is certainty and so you will choose this
particular thing and this is called the
threshold choices or this isn't making
no decisions which involve
overconfidence and judgment are attained
a minimum level of certainty to easily
read into choice of longer and dividing
choices now what does it really mean now
when once we become overconfident with a
particular judgment once we display some
kind of overconfidence we increase or we
get in the minimum level of certainty is
reached at a very early stage and so at
this point of time the wrong or
unrewarding choices can come now going
back to this incident in which a and B
are two washing machines or companies
which are offering washing machine and C
is an accessory let's say that I trust a
so much and the fact that since a is a
company which has always been offering
something for minimum rates or with
giving things for free and so with this
trust I have an over confidence that a
is going to launch a machine with
manufacturer or a product a is going to
launch this machine and I am confident
am more confident with the fact that it
is going to give free because previous
seasons or previous a buying of this
product shows that this particular
manufacturer gifting
three I am then leading to something
called overconfidence and this will lead
to wrong choices because it may so
happen that although you get C for free
but a may not be very good and so
overconfidence actually leads to
attaining off or selecting up punk
choices so if people are overconfident
in making a choice if people ignore
certain facts and becomes show over
confidences in in accepting a number of
choices out of judgment they turn on or
they basically invite something called
faulty choices no basic question which
comes with it is that is there a minimum
level of certainty which varies with
culture so is it true that certain
cultures are overconfident than certain
other cultures and so there is there was
a study done by Yeats Lee and shamoto
suka in 1996 where the Asian culture and
the you and the and the Western culture
was compared and so in this study what
really happened is the overconfidence
effect was tested in people from us and
Taiwan and so a situation was given to
people from both these situations or
both both these countries in which they
were told or they were given this
profile that a particular two medicines
have been invented for a particular kind
of two different kinds of diseases which
are there and so this since these two
diseases are very similar in nature very
similar in in in symptoms these are the
two different kinds of medicines that
they work on to it and then they were
asked to give this medicine basically
provide these medicines for these two
kinds of diseases so basically - this is
a different kind of diseases or two kind
of diseases were thrown in which had
similar symptoms and two kind of
medicines were prescribed for or two
kinds of medicines we're given or were
suggested for these two kinds of
diseases and then it was people from
both these cultures were asked to go
ahead and diagnose what is the looking
at a profile of a patient and so several
profiles were given to the evaluators
from both the countries and they were
then asked to basically then diagnose
the kind of disease that they have
then give the medicine this is the kind
of setup which was that and so people
from both Taiwan and us actually went
ahead and did that what really happened
what was the result of an experiment
like this it was found out that in
general people were more confident and
in the sense that people showed
overconfidence in terms of assigning a
particular disease to a particular
symptom so particular disease are
assigning a particular medicine to a
particular disease so they were
overconfident that but in general the
results showed that people from Taiwan
were more confident and made more number
of errors in terms of assigning the
wrong medicine to the wrong kind of
disease remember initially I said that
what happened here was that the two
diseases had similar symptoms and so two
different medicines were given to two
different kind of diseases but then
people from Taiwan may were more
confident and made more errors than
people from the Western culture of the
United States why could this be what is
the reason for this kind of
overconfidence and this kind of a more
error-prone s and so what are the
reasons for this was right of the fact
that people from Asian culture from
Taiwanese culture they depended more on
their memory and so they searched more
of their memory and use more of their
memory in terms of finding or the
symptoms or assigning the symptoms
whereas people from the Western cultures
they referred to written manuals and so
they were more correct whereas people
from the Asian cultures they they
depended more on their memory of what
they have learnt and assigning a
medicine and so one of the reason is
this has to be one of the reasons just
provided was this kind of a dependence
on memory versus dependent not written
literature or written directives and
following these directives which is the
result for minimal level of certain it
is with various cultures now this isn't
making in decision-making there are
several models which have been used and
so one other there are two different
kinds of model which have been used in
decision-making one is called the
normative model and the other is called
the descriptive model so in the
normative model as we saw in in the
chapter on
or in the section on reasoning we saw
there are two different models of
reasoning also one is called the
normative models and the other is called
the descriptive models the normative
models are the models which are ideal
which are the ones which should be
followed and these are rational models
so normative models are those models
which actually should be followed in a
situation or those models which have
been prescribed or those model which are
prescribed for any kind of an
investigation or any kind of use and
descriptive models are those models
which actually are not ideal models but
which make a goal attainment easy and so
these are the models which kept people
actually follow so let's say if there
are if there is a problem which needs to
be solved there it can be solved in two
vases one is using analog e or one is
using algorithmic approach ends in
algorithmic approach using the algorithm
is basically a normative model because
here everything will go in always a
fraction and a result is expected out of
it whereas in the descriptive model
people use heuristic approaches people
use heuristics to apply or to come up
with a solution and so they they do not
follow these ideal solutions or they use
some kind of a rules of thumb to arrive
at a solution and so these are the two
different kinds of models and so one of
these normative models way of
decision-making is called the expected
utility model or the EU model to be
brief now what is this model this is a
model which have been borrowed from
economics so acquire mix are interested
in the factors involved in choice and
what's the type of model which describe
a rational choice and behavior so thus
basically in an expected utility model
the idea is that how do we can amidst
want to know what are the factors with
which makes people choose between
alternatives so given the fact that you
have a number of water keys which comes
out of judgment how do you go ahead and
make a choice and once make a choice
what is the model which describes a
rational choice now what is the rational
choice a rational choice of choice which
provides you the better good which
basically means the rational choice is
that choice which provides which leads
you to goal attainment
with minimum or losses and so a rational
choices that choice which has which
maximizes gains and minimizes loss to
maximizes gains in the sense that you
get more gain or out of it but even if
you don't gain then you do not lose too
much so what a rational choice is choice
which maximizes which tends to maximize
gains and minimize loss a situation like
this now what are the wireless
stablished theories of decision making
is something called the expected utility
theory which comes from economics and
what is this theory so the theory states
that when faced with some type of
uncertainties when because in
decision-making it's always uncertainty
because we don't have enough of
information available to us so we make
decisions under uncertainty and risk so
the fact that when people make decisions
and uncertainty we make our decision
based on two factors generally when we
make decisions and when this decision is
under uncertainty when we once we don't
know all the information which is
available we don't know all the facts
which are available to us we tend to
make decisions with two factors with two
different under two different factors
one is the expected utility of the
outcome so any decision which is
rational according to the expected
utility choice or expected utility
theory is to be made in terms of the how
much the expected utility of the earth
of each outcome is now we'll define
utility now in a while so the one one
factor which defines a rational choice a
choice which gives maximizes ghee and
minimizes loss is the one which provides
the expected U which provides the
maximum utility and the second is what
is the respective probability so the
probability of the outcome versus in x
the expected utility the outcome will
define a rational choice
so basically expected utility theory
says the expected utility is equivalent
to the utility of the outcome into the
probability of all outcomes and so this
has been done so we have done for the
iith outcome it can be four and number
four
and so if there are three outcomes let's
say IJ and K we find out the expected
utility for I at item for JH item and
for K at item and based on this we then
go ahead and tend to make the choice in
which we have the maximum utility and
the highest probability of the outcome
being offered now utility refers to
whatever end what is utility how do we
define utility so utility refers to
whatever end a person would like to
achieve it is basically what do you want
to get out of a particular decision it
is that particular thing that you want
to get at the end of the season me it
could be happiness it could be money it
could be something else
satisfaction or whatever it is no broom
1991 they suggest that utility refers to
the amount of wood that comes out of a
decision so basically once we make a
decision
what is the benefit that we are getting
out of it what is the good that we are
getting out of it so utility is
basically defined in terms of the
greater good which comes out of making a
decision now thus while making a
decision we weigh the good that might
come out with each alternative against
the cost of that alternative so when we
make a particular kind of a utility
assessment of a particular outcome we
look at what is the good that comes out
of it and what is the payment that we
are making what is the sacrifice that we
are making to get a particular good of
that water is the point of particular
kind of a sacrifice that we are making
in acquiring or in selecting a
particular alternative and what is this
or one selected what is the good that
this alternative is going to provide to
us we also access the probability of
each of the alternative occurring we
also look at where if there are four
alternatives what is the probability of
an alternative happening let's say that
if there are four alternatives one
alternative or the probability of
happening which is 0.8 80% of times and
one alternative has the or the
probability of happening which is only
1% time now the fact that if there is
the alternative which has one of the
probability of occurring upon there's
only one person that should not be
chosen because it will never occur or it
will never
be available and so we should not select
that thing and so that particular
alternative so not only the utility say
if an outcome presence or if your
outcome gives you greater utility if it
is very good for you
but then the chances of this thing
particular happening is very less we
should not take that outcome we should
take only that outcome
which provides utility in Association or
in addition to its probability also a
probability of occurrence also which
means that the availability of it so if
a particular choice is available is
vastly available and provides even if
less good then some some other
alternative which are very less
formative occurring we should choose
that and that is called the rational
decision making so whether or take is
provide the best combination of good and
the likelihood will be choosen for
example let's consider this example
let's look at look at these two options
which are there now if you flip a coin
it turns up head and you get $40 now if
you roll a dice it comes up four you get
a $50 no which is the choice that you
are going to make if you look at the
expected utility if you look at through
the lens of expected utility here you're
getting a more higher dollar amount then
in this case but then people generally
go ahead and take this see the utility
is 40 here the utility is 50 here but
the probability of if you can if you
calculate the expected utility the value
is 40 here right and the probability of
getting a head is 1/2 whereas the
probability of getting a 4 is 1 by 6 and
so in this case if you look into if you
calculate the expected utility or the
second is less or the expected good that
is going to get the appropriateness of
this is lesser than this because the
probability of 4 is 1 by 6 a probability
getting a 4 in a throw of dice because
there are 6 faces of a dice and getting
a 4 is 1 by 6 and so in this case this
is more lucrative than this although
this is a lesser dollar remark now which
options would you choose and definitely
the option that you are going to choose
is the one which is the first one and so
this
the expected utility tree now generally
speaking this is a mechanical theory
it's an economic theory or mechanical
theory of choice behavior or
decision-making and so generally
speaking how people make decision is
they violate this expected utility and
the violation comes in terms of in
variances of choices let's look at what
is in variances of choices now what are
the normative predictions that need to
be expected from the utility theory is
that our choice should be invariant now
one of the predictions which comes from
this expected utility theory is the fact
that the choice that we make for a
particular option should be invariant
which means that you want if we choose a
under situation one then we should stick
with our choice and say under situation
- but that's not what happens let's say
that there are two in the previous case
only given the fact that you choose the
first one or the second one or the
choices you take the choice of rolling a
dice and flipping a coin and you choose
the $50 option given the fact that if
situation changes how does the situation
change the fact that it's the fact this
becomes an even number if some situation
changes in the fact that you know that
the dice is biased in such a way that it
will always fall towards even numbers
now if this situation changes even then
you should consider or you should go
with this dice or the fact that you come
to know that the coin that is being
flipped is somehow biased is in the it
will always in it will give more number
of heads than tails then you should not
be varying your choices and then why is
this kind of a thing there or why is
this kind of an invariance not being
followed the people don't follow this
invariance or they change change their
outcome or this change there this is in
process and this is called the in
variances or people show in variances of
choices and this is what one of the
violations of expected utility theory
now what is it that a decision makers
choice should not depend on the way a
choice is presented so if a choice is
presented in a negative frame or
positive frame which means that if it's
positively worded or negatively worded
people should not go ahead and make flip
between their choices if you make a
particular choice if you have concede
all the information if you make a
particular kind of a choice you should
not be going ahead and flipping between
choices that should be one of the things
so example if I prefer choice a or
choice B in situation 1 then I should
prefer choice a or choice B in situation
number 14 as long as a and B are
identical in two situations so if
situation changes if some other things
in the external environment changes
people should not be changing their
choices but this is what doesn't happen
and this is called preference reversal
or in variances of choices now people
often switch their preferences from one
outcome to another as situation changes
people go on changing their choices and
so this is one of the problems with the
following off of the expected utility
theory I mean the expected entry theorem
the fact is and given the fact that a
particular option is chose particular
kind of utility to you it is highly
utilized good providing you higher good
and it the probability of it offering is
also the same if situation changes you
should not be changing your options but
people do change so people often change
their preferences of one outcome over
another based on how these ought comes
are presented demonstrating irrational
irrationality and this is basically what
is called irrationality this is what
people show in terms of irrationality
now consider the preference reversal
which is shown so live latest in and
Slovak 1971 they showed something called
a preference reversal and they showed
this violation of expected utility
through a phenomena which is called
preference reversal now the general
procedure involved having subjects look
at two different Gamble's and decide one
which gamble they would like to play and
number two how much the gamble was worth
so given the fact that people were given
six different choices and so in each
choices I show you the choice which has
been given to that there are six
different choices to people and each
each one of has a winning percentage so
there is there is a probability of this
gamble happening and then there is a
utility of it happening and but the
situation changes so understand that
each of these choices have a particular
utility and a particular probability now
the fact is two different options or two
different things are there in
case you are the one who's playing this
gamble or who's playing this kind of a
game and the other case you are the one
who's owning the gamble and you want to
sell this gamble or you want to other
people to gamble on this in which in the
first case which gamble are you going to
choose in the second case which gamble
are you going to choose let me give you
one minute time to basically go ahead
and make your choice
if you are the one who's playing which
gamble or which of these choices are
that that you are going to basically
accept or which are the these choices
are the one which are going to play but
if you are the one who is the owner of
this gamble and want other people to
invest in this which is the choice that
you are going to choose now as you would
understand that if you are the one who's
going to play most people choose this
gamble because there's a 99% choice as a
probability of winning so you win only
for dollars but the chance of winning is
higher so you the chances of winning are
higher people actually when they play a
gamble this is what they bet into but if
you are the one who holds this gamble if
you want other people to to basically go
ahead and put an e or play your gamble
we will look into something like this in
which case 33% that you win 16 dollars
so you will now look at the higher
amount of money right so it is the money
value in which so you put more money on
to a higher gamble and so the very fact
as it appears to be the fact that people
should be choosing this in both the
cases that is not how it is one use once
you own the gamble you would want other
people to get attracted by the money
value but the fact that is the higher
money value has a lower probability of
winning is the one gamble that you will
choose but when you are playing it you
will play that gamble which has higher
certainty but lower gambling money so
this is how preference reversal happens
so one was I am playing I will always
look at a gamble which has higher
certainty of being played or higher
certainty of giving me even if it is
giving me lower values but when I am
selling a gamble I will always think of
a gamble in which higher value money is
there
but the chances of winning it are very
less and that is what we need to do and
so in this in in this case I'll this
will be the particular gamble where I
own so while owning I will own this but
while playing I'll play this and so this
is called preference labor self no let's
just in in slow way expected the choice
of which gamble to play would be
influenced by the probability of winning
whereas the choice of selling price for
the gamble would depend on the partial
dollar amount to be won so if you want
looking at the amount of dollar that is
do we want that and is the decision
factor in selling a gamble but when you
are playing the gamble it is the
probability of winning which decides you
how or why you are going to play a
particular gamble now why is this
preference reversal irrational what is
the reason for the irrational
irrationality the preference reversal
phenomena demonstrates the inadequacy of
expected utility as a descriptive model
of decision making the utility model
fails to provide a good description of
how we make choices the utility model
doesn't reflect how humans actually go
ahead and make choices the utility model
is very good in terms of economic
factors in terms of prices in terms of
other non living entity but when can
when it comes to humans it is very
difficult to understand how people make
choices now in many circumstances
because assumes as much human rarely
have them because it assumes as much
know the expected utility theorem it
understands or it assumes that humans
have all the information necessary for
making a choice but it is to be noted
that humans do not have all the
information which is available or with
humans do not have all the information
available for making a choice at any
point of time so you must rarely have
all the available information necessary
to make a decision even if they did they
do not have they lack the ability to
combine and weigh all the information
accurately and so this is one of the
reason or this is one of the factor in
which or this is one of the
reason why there is this preference
reversal so in terms of machines in
terms of economics in terms of prices
the expected utility theory or theorem
is the one which fits but with humans it
doesn't fit in the sense that humans do
not first of all have all the
information for making the choices and
so most of the times they are irrational
in making the choices or they show
irrationality and the other reason is
even if they have all the information
present or possible they are not able to
combine all the information to make the
right kind of a choice because this
computation this calculation requires a
lot of other factors to be there and so
this is the reason why people do this
preference reversal or switch choices
now in addition to the expected utility
theory there is something called the
multi attribute utility theory and what
is the multi attribute totally a theory
it's an extension of the expected
utility theory
now what if choices differ on many
dimensions now given the fact that in
expected utility Theory there was just
one dimension on which the choice was
wearing now if the choice is varying on
number of dimensions or number of
variables we use something called a
multi utility theory or a multi
attribute really a theory example
choosing a major in college now if
you're choosing a major in college it is
not the goal of becoming a doctor that
is making you take a medical field there
could be several other things for
example how close is the campus from
your home how pleasing is the campus in
this so many other variables which lets
you decide a particular College a
particular medical college to go to and
so once we are doing that there are
multi attributes for multiple dimensions
on which the final decision is dependent
so major differences in many ways as you
are interested in them your job market
after graduation the faculty etc and so
number of variables will actually go
ahead and decide not just one goal of
becoming a doctor that how should one
make the choice
first of all in multi attribute utility
Theory as against the expected into
theory where there is one choice and one
utility there if there are multiple
utilities and multiple probabilities
based in people need to first make
decision down it's important dimension
we have to understand those dimensions
which are important to us and those
dimensions which are not important has
to be thrown out or given lower voltages
determine the relative weights
importance of each dimension
each dimension which
there for example one other dimension
that people are for example for me other
dimensions are choosing colleges how
near it is to my hometown and that was
one of the highest and I gave it the
highest weight and so other things got
lower weight weight is basically how
much preferable that dimension or that
particular attribute is to me and so we
give the kind of weights then we have to
list all the alternatives of which are
available with their weights and run the
ranked the alternatives around each
dimension and then multiply each ranking
by the appropriate weight which leads us
to choosing the alternative with the
highest value for example look into this
suppose this is a this is a particular
scenario which I have created so then
the the criteria on which you want to
select a school is interesting topic job
prospects faculty in Department and
requirements this is the important ways
that you give to it and these are the
majors that you would like to choose and
so once you look into this the each one
of it has multiplied by the weight will
give you a final summary score this is
the multi attribute theory this is the
equal weighted criteria and this is the
top criterion based on that you will
then finally be able to decide which
college you would like to go and which
college you would like to avoid and so
this is the multi attribute theory which
is again a normative model of decision
making thank you
[Music]
you